[inaudible]
the day that thougth invented writing
famous warned him that he discovered a
drug that would make people
lose touch with themselves.
If you're still watching, you took
thoughts, pill in software yourself.
The effects it really had. It started
with visual depictions of the world.
Pictographs signs for ideas
and thoughts, idiot graphs.
Then a transformation from picture
writing to true writing with symbols that
stand out
for words, logo, graphs, using
those words. Symbols to Sanford,
similar sounding words. Rebus.
Then those sound alikes became
syllable characters, sullen berries,
continent characters, object ads, and
then consonant and vowel characters,
alphabets or even constant and
val syllables or Facila Berries,
and if things get really linguistic
savvy off of that to become all featural
characters grouped by their
phonetic properties along the way,
writing had to deal with
tensions and take sides.
Should it represent meanings or sounds?
Should it benefit the reader or the
writer contained maximum information about
every sound or just enough to
recognize the shape of a word?
Should it be flexible and
creative or rigid and consistent?
How do physical techniques shape
it? Oh Hen who did it first?
Who did it best.
Maybe you've learned to make some
sense out of the chaotic noise of world
writing.
Maybe you can appreciate some of the
problems each one solves the traditions
that captures the ambiguity's at creates,
or perhaps it's more comfortable just
to close your eyes and wake up back at
home.
Looking at your familiar characters of
your familiar writing system plastered
across your favorite websites.
Still somehow you can't even
look at that the same way.
It's just one invention among many
in the long history of this language
technology we call fighting
[inaudible].